he's a Baker Mayfield back on the
program good to talk to him did you fill
out a bracket Baker I have not yet I'm
actually doing that last minute this
morning okay how far will you have your
Sooners going you can be in our bracket
challenge if you want to once you fill
out a bracket and then we'll let people
follow along with your brackets how's
that nobody involved I work okay I work
did you play basketball growing up no
actually terrible basketball player so
March Madness is you know me watching
and wishing that I could ever be there
so it's not a reality for me
did you lose a little big man on campus
status with Trey young at the beginning
of the basketball season at all but like
if he walked around council II did what
happened he came in a really strong he
came in really strong for an 18 year old
but if uh if you were running for campus
president if you ran for campus
president in December against him who
would have won well before Theismann or
after before Heisman I think I think he
might want it he had people going crazy
up here in Oklahoma there's the Heisman
by the way I think it's in coach Riley's
office for recruiting purposes got it
when do you get it back or is it going
to stay there it's not gonna stay there
so there's two of them to give one of
the school they just wonderful so I
guess they're the ones being made and I
don't have that one cut at home pretty
soon how relieved are you to have that
pro day out of the way you know all the
workouts and whatnot for me an hour
pretty much done I had some private
things set up
come down to the 24th but other than
that all the formal throwing all that
you know you talk about the lights
camera action for all
stealth is over with it feels good but
you're also doing sort of behind the
scenes aren't you aren't you doing a
documentary yeah but you have been
filming that for a little bit excited to
have that being announced and I'm moving
forward it should be should be pretty
cool you know everybody does their kind
of a past draft type stuff but ours is
uh a little bit next-level a little more
behind the scenes and you know shows you
a little bit everything that comes with
this process right now and it's identify
launches new series next level behind
Baker a docu-series following you there
were cameras with you when you were in
Minnesota weren't they they were they
were there and then I saw him yesterday
at the pro day yes yes there's a couple
cameras there in support yesterday where
did you watch the Super Bowl phone
Airport kind of getting stuck in
traveling mode you were at the airport
like terminal C in Minneapolis watching
the Superbowl
no partially when I had got back to
California and partially when I actually
got home what's your favorite team drona
oh no the Packers yes he talked about it
was a breast pump guy so who's on my
squad
are they still your team don't have one
yet so I'm saying I'm picking up one
here here pretty soon
late April do you have any idea where
you're going you know you get kind of a
good idea of where seems like you know
how interested they are but you know who
brings you in for visits and whatnot but
you know your stories of guys that I
didn't even met with teams and then they
they get drafted by oh so quite honestly
no I'd like to say that I do but I
really don't because there are teams
that have drafted players who didn't
even go in an interview with him which
you know like Blake bortles I think with
Jacksonville they
hid the fact that they were gonna take
him that high so somebody may take you
that you who's in who's ignored you the
most Baker I think that's what we want
to know we have Patriots the eagle is
only obviously they're pretty set at
quarterback there's a couple more
Cowboys things like that that they got
young guys bucking the errors that
they're happy wasn't they have so
another talked all he's Baker Mayfield
former Oklahoma quarterback he has a new
docu-series it's called next level
behind Baker on identified that'll be
when does that come out by the way so
it's gonna be a little serious
depression episodes out shortly here
planning on pushing a couple out and
then after all these episodes you know
release we're gonna have a longer
documentary about a 90-minute feature
[Music]
how much of your job is to be an
entertainer when you go to the NFL Bobby
Taylor is and I'll just getting my job
done being responsible you know doing
things I'll need you to be a franchise
quarterback so I wouldn't say
entertainer I'd say you know responsible
for getting the job done at winning and
then second just be in the face of the
franchise how uncomfortable is it poked
prodded questions everything the last
couple of weeks here it's quite the
interesting process you know you
this is not like recruiting or anything
else this is you know they try and find
every single flaw with you they try to
find whatever is wrong with you to ask
you about your family your background
all the way back down to preschool you
know try and see what type of guy you
are and how you're going to handle when
you're making money playing football
what you're going to do
from city you know yeah there's a bunch
of questions
it's interesting how everybody else
handles it but yeah you you prepare for
this right do you sit down and then you
get your agent or people advisors say
alright when they ask you this you
answer this way or how are you going to
did you do that where you sort of have a
mock interview process I never had that
some guys do it but I've always been one
I'm just going to be myself and those
and those questions and be honest and
upfront about it so I'm answering who
they're gonna pick up so I'm not gonna
try and put on some front and answer
these questions in the perfect way I'm
gonna I'm gonna be me and this day and
they like that then it's gonna be the
right fit and there's not and that's oh
quarters a lot of the places says that
what was the question that caught you
off guard or you'd like another chance
at answering hey there was one meeting
at the combine that started out it was
just straight elementary school
multiplication subtraction division
there were about 15 of them in a row so
it started out like two plus four and
then went from there times this divided
by their subtract add multiply divide
and I just kept doing it so pretty
interesting considering I will never
ever do those problems ever again
so it seemed really irrelevant to play
the game of football wait wait so it was
two plus two then you go for four times
five and then you go 20 divided by 10
like so that's what they were doing I
stuff like that exactly and then they
start the actual meeting from there I
don't know it's a lot of this stuff I
think they try and get you flustered
with you know just random questions and
then somebody else is talking in the
background and then they see if you can
translate from from there to talking
about the game and being calm about it
still getting the job done
Twitter reaction to the bandana
yesterday was fun did you read any of
those tweets
I only saw a couple actually there's
some pretty yeah pretty entertaining
what is it you know a hat and the pro
day since I think you know sensei so
don't don't wear your hat backwards
medial go crazy don't do that yeah yeah
yeah I know I forgot I can't wear a
headband to a workout I got somebody
that Origen I saw this because whenever
somebody talks trash is Oklahoma fans
but they jump on him so I tagged in
about 50 times I don't know who he is
but he said me wearing that to an
interview was the wrong wrong idea the
wrong thing to do so
forgot I couldn't wear my headband suit
to a football function Wow a little
sensitive there how about a suit and tie
and and then you have the bandana and
then tweet tweet that held all business
and then you wear your your bandana may
be Ralph Macchio who played The Karate
Kid maybe we get him to uh to reach out
and sign off on that actually yeah you
know keep being yourself have fun with
it you know it's gonna it'll be over
and then all of a sudden you know you'll
look back and you know if you don't
enjoy it so hopefully you're doing that
now where you gonna be on draft day I'll
be at home with my family watching it
with them and group of friends and just
honestly kind of hanging out with them
you know it's not it's not about just me
on that draft day there's a lot more
people that helped me out along the way
will you have the bandana on on draft
day absolutely not okay well you know
Favre had cutoff jeans on he had jean
shorts on drafting he had shorts on are
you are you encouraging how about jean
shorts as an homage to Brett Favre we
actually that can be arranged you have a
pair of those jean shorts is what you're
saying yes
yeah hey Congrats so far hitting them
yeah have fun with it and good luck with
the documentary thank you very much and
by the way I do apologize I owe you I
apologize I tried with Justin Timberlake
he can only take you so far sometimes I
know and I and I failed you know what I
I had a bad moment there it was like the
big man yeah I mean I I said to
Timberlake hey you know and I was
explaining all of this to him when I sat
down with him at the Super Bowl
I couldn't he couldn't turn it around on
short notice and use you in the Super
Bowl performance but it the topic was
broached just so you know and he knew
who you were he appreciated that but he
he couldn't work you in the Super Bowl
and by the way you left the you didn't
even stay for the Super Bowl so because
I wasn't working that's what I thought
that's what I thought I'm not gonna give
up on this I'll get you at a Justin
Timberlake backup answer roll one of
these days all right okay thank you I
appreciate them oh you're growing all
right good luck on draft day Thank You
Baker thank you
all right that's Baker Mayfield jr. the
third for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]